They may not be as necessary
to a franchise as some others,
but these sequels are definitely worth
watching. And if you haven't heard of them,
you aren't alone. These are the best
movie sequels you've never watched.
Few films have had an impact as
great as 1939's The Wizard of Oz.
Adapted from L. Frank Baum's novel The
Wonderful Wizard of Oz, not only was the
film representative of the height of technology,
but it confirmed Judy Garland as a bona fide star.
The Wizard of Oz was nominated for six Academy
Awards, including Best Picture, and according
to the Library of Congress, it's been watched
more than any other movie. Critically beloved,
it's a true American classic that continues
to have an impact on audiences today.
Forty-five years later, Return
to Oz finds young Dorothy Gale,
now played by Fairuza Balk, on a new adventure
back to Oz, only this trip is much, much darker.
Gone are the friendly residents
of Munchkinland and the familiar
faces that belonged to Dorothy's Yellow Brick
Road companions. Emerald City lies in ruins,
overrun by the appropriately named Wheelers,
creatures with wheels for hands and feet.
"Come here… chicken."
To say that Return to Oz is a strange
second serving would be an understatement.
The movie has little to do with its
predecessor outside of its central,
decidedly less musical, heroine. It came in
seventh at the box office its opening weekend,
bringing in less than $3 million on a
$28 million budget. Critics were split,
with many noting its darker tone as either
its most positive or most negative attribute.
Still, it's attracted a cult following in the
years since its release. And if a princess with
a collection of heads is more your speed
than a wicked witch with flying monkeys,
Return to Oz is certainly a worthwhile endeavor.
Brian De Palma's 1976 horror classic Carrie
marked the first of many Stephen King adaptations.
The story of teenage outcast Carrie White, who
discovers she has telekinetic abilities to a
murderous degree, Carrie is generally regarded
as one of, if not the best of King's adaptations,
and it's considered to be one of the
greatest horror films ever made. It's
also gone on to inspire two remakes and a
sequel, decades after its initial release.
While a remake of the horror classic should
be expected, a Carrie sequel is something that
requires a little more finesse. After all, the
original film ends with the teenager's death — it
doesn't get much more final than that. Unless, of
course, Carrie were to have a secret half-sister
with the exact same untapped telekinetic
potential, which is the general premise for
1999's The Rage: Carrie 2. Starring Emily Bergl
as said sibling Rachel Lang, the film follows the
same general beats as its predecessor — members of
the in crowd play the less popular kid for laughs;
she loses control of her abilities;
everything — and everyone — goes to hell.
The Rage couldn't impress critics or
audiences, and its lasting legacy is
as a disposable relic of '90s era teen
horror. But it's an entertaining watch,
if for no other reason than the fact that it
made an attempt to expand on the original's lore,
as opposed to just rehashing it altogether.
And Bergl is solid as Rachel, who turns out
to be a more sympathetic character on account of
having at least some measure of social ability.
1996's Trainspotting was an instant hit and a true
encapsulation of '90s indie cinema. The portrait
of addiction and poverty in suburban Edinburgh,
based on Irvine Welsh's same-named novel,
centers on a group of heroin-addicted friends
led by Mark Renton as they struggle with
sobriety and everyday existence. It spoke to
an entire generation of lost souls, and its
unflinching po ayal of abuse was highlighted by a
dark humor and an incredible soundtrack. In 1999,
the British Film Institute named Trainspotting
the tenth best British film of the century.
Two decades later, the original cast reunited
with director Danny Boyle for T2 Trainspotting,
which sees Renton return to his old
neighborhood as his marriage falls apart,
he suffers a heart attack, and the impending
doom of middle age looms around the corner.
"Choose Facebook. Twitter. Snapchat, Instagram,
and a thousand other ways to spew your
bile across people you've never met."
This go-around, Renton and his pals find
themselves caught up in a legal mess revolving
around the operation of an illegal brothel.
Although T2 performed well internationally,
it had a quiet opening in America, bringing in
less than $200,000 its first weekend. Still,
the film did well with critics, who praised
its emotionally resonant portrayal of a
group of people struggling to move forward
from their past mistakes. It may not be as
innovative as its predecessor, but it still
speaks to those who grew up with the original
and may not yet have completely found their way.
In the realm of science fiction, there
is perhaps no film more influential than
Stanley Kubrick's 1968 masterpiece 2001: A Space
Odyssey. Set largely aboard the Jupiter-bound
spacecraft Discovery One, 2001 tells the story
of a mysterious monolith, the group of astronauts
sent to investigate it, and the onboard computer
system that ultimately turns against them.
The film was nominated for four Academy Awards,
winning one for Best Special Visual Effects,
and is today regarded as one of the most
culturally significant films ever made.
It remains a topic of discussion
for film fans and scholars alike.
Peter Hyams' 1984 followup 2010: The Year We Make
Contact was never going to be able to reach the
bar that 2001 had set, but it definitely tries.
Nine years after the Discovery One incident,
a joint US/Soviet mission is
sent out to uncover the truth.
2010 further explores the presence
and meaning of the monolith, although,
like 2001, the audience is left with more
questions than answers about its true purpose.
2010 did fairly well at the box office, opening
in second place with a $7 million haul. Response
from critics was overall favorable, but its
biggest problem isn't that it's not a good
sci-fi movie — it really is. It's that
it isn't a Stanley Kubrick sci-fi movie.
Taken on its own merits, 2010 turns out to be one
of the more enjoyable space-set films of the '80s.
There's a benefit to following a film that's never
been considered a classic or a masterpiece, one
that hasn't set any box office or awards records.
When expectations are low (or nonexistent),
you can really do anything you want. 1978's
Attack of the Killer Tomatoes was no critical
darling — the film, about a country besieged
by mutated carnivorous tomatoes and the team
of specialists tasked with saving the day, has
received mostly negative reviews over the years.
In spite of this, Attack of the Killer Tomatoes
is a bona fide cult classic that's launched an
entire franchise of sequels, novels,
video games, and kids' cartoons.
The approach to its first sequel, 1988's
Return of the Killer Tomatoes!, was one of the
"throw everything at the wall and see what sticks"
variety. A decade after the Great Tomato War,
tomatoes have been outlawed. Everything seems to
be going well until Professor Mortimer Gangreen,
the never-spoken-of true villain behind the
first film's attack, figures out a way to
reverse-engineer the music that brought
about his initial defeat to his favor,
transforming tomatoes into human beings. Our
heroes in this installment are pizza boy Chad,
tomato-turned-human Tara, Chad's best friend
Matt, and a poorly mutated tomato named FT.
Like its predecessor, Return of the
Killer Tomatoes! is completely ridiculous,
but where Attack of the Killer
Tomatoes is just a parody of B-movies,
Return of the Killer Tomatoes! is a parody of
a parody, which somehow makes it a better film.
(Gangrene laughs, then coughs)
From fourth wall breaking to unnecessary product
placement and fuzzy mutated pet adventures,
it's beyond anything in its
genre — which is a good thing.
The Star Trek franchise is vast and long-running,
one that follows multiple crews and which has
lasted more than half a century. Since 1979,
13 Star Trek films have been made, although
only three crews have made it to the big screen…
two, if we're counting the J.J. Abrams alternate
timeline one as just a variation of the original.
The film series has had its fair share of
ups and downs, and while one might assume
an eighth film would have a difficult time
standing up against some of its predecessors,
1996's Star Trek: First Contact
managed to take everyone by surprise.
"I bring order to chaos."
The followup to 1994's Generations, which
effectively passed the motion picture torch from
Kirk's Enterprise to Picard's, First Contact is
the first of the Star Trek films to focus solely
on the Next Generation crew. It also
revisits one of its greatest storylines:
the battle with the Borg. Years after Picard's
assimilation into and escape from the Collective,
a new Borg threat sends the crew of the Enterprise
back in time to save Earth from mass assimilation.
First Contact has been hailed as one
of the best films in the entire series,
with critics praising both the film's
performances and its direction,
which comes courtesy of Number One himself,
Jonathan Frakes. It's a truly interesting, updated
take on the story, and having a big-screen budget
to tell it definitely works to the film's benefit.
By 2011, the world had grown weary of Sidney
Prescott and her seemingly never-ending parade of
obsessed mask-wearing murderous psychos. Scream 3,
which hit theaters in 2000, was panned by critics,
who claimed the film fell back on the same
old cliches the franchise had once destroyed.
Still, it managed to nearly make up for its
entire cost its first weekend at the box office,
so the studio system trudged
forward, greenlighting a fourth
installment in the franchise. Hopes
for greatness weren't exactly high.
But Scream 4 turned out to be
more than just a passable sequel.
Returning to its roots, the film features two
Ghostface killers working in tandem: Jill Roberts,
Sidney's jealous, fame-hungry cousin, and
Charlie Walker, Jill's secret boyfriend and
horror movie aficionado. The rules, however,
have changed — in this Scream installment,
we find the killers are
adhering to movie remake rules.
"Modern audiences get savvy to the rules of the
originals. So the reversals
become the new standard."
It's a small change from the
franchise's original formula,
but it's enough to make this particular
sequel stand out. Having killer stars
Emma Roberts and Rory Culkin inject some
much-needed fresh blood into the franchise
is an added bonus — their performances are what
ultimately makes the movie, and it's fun to
check out Roberts play with villainy prior to her
memorable turn on American Horror Story: Coven.
When it hit theaters in 1978, no one
suspected that John Carpenter's Halloween,
a low-budget slasher about a boogeyman
in a spray-painted Captain Kirk mask
and mechanic's coveralls who stalks a babysitter
and kills all her friends along the way,
would become the phenomenon it did. The film
set the stage for what much of horror would
go on to look like in the following years,
and it's since become not only a classic,
but required viewing for anyone even
remotely interested in the genre.
Michael Myers is an icon, and it's hard to
imagine the world of Halloween movies without him.
But it wasn't always meant to be this
way. Carpenter's intention was to
have the Michael Myers story end with the
first film — after its success, Carpenter,
quote, "had to" write the sequel, but, as he
explained to The Hollywood Reporter in 2015,
"I thought that we were done with telling stories
about Michael Myers and the guy in the mask.
I thought there's not much more to say. So
we thought we'd come up with a new story
every year. We could call it Halloween, but it
didn't have to do anything with Michael Myers."
And so in 1982, we got Halloween III: Season
of the Witch, a film that swaps out Michael
Myers for a piece of Stonehenge and some cursed
Halloween masks, and which tells the story of
one man's plot to sacrifice a bunch of children
in order to bring about a new age of witchcraft.
Halloween III may not have been a hit with critics
who'd expected another Michael Myers installment,
but it's since developed its own fanbase — one
that doesn't need a masked maniac at Halloween.
There's no denying the overwhelming
appeal of 1984's horror comedy Gremlins.
Centered on a family who unwittingly unleashes
a horde of mischievous monsters upon the
small town of Kingston Falls, Gremlins
combines holiday fantasy with outright terror,
taking on a consumer culture with
a little water and some sunlight.
It proved to be a massive hit, raking
in over $12 million its opening weekend.
A few years later, the cast and crew reunited,
and, hoping to strike gold twice, Gremlins 2:
The New Batch hit theaters in June of 1990. While
the basic premise of the original story is here,
for the most part, Gremlins 2 is a movie all its
own. Both films are horror comedies, but Gremlins
2 takes the story in a more lighthearted direction
than its predecessor, relying more on parody
for laughs. It's over the top in its comedic
excess — Joe Dante, who directed both films,
told Bloody Disgusting in 2015 that he
never wanted to make a sequel but was given,
quote, "three times the money" along with the
freedom to do whatever he wanted. He explained:
"So I made Gremlins 2, which was essentially about
how there didn't need to be a sequel to Gremlins."
"I can't believe this. I mean,
this is worse than the first one."
"We just show these movies,
madame, we don't make them."
Regardless of how it came to be, Gremlins 2 is
one of those sequels that fans should hold as near
and dear to their hearts as the original, even if
it is just making fun of itself the entire time.
Demonic possession has served as Hollywood horror
fodder for decades. The most famous of these films
is, of course, 1973's The Exorcist, William
Friedkin's take on William Peter Blatty's 1971
novel that centers on Regan, a young girl who
falls under the control of a demon named Pazuzu,
and on Father Damien Karras, a priest struggling
with his faith who's tasked with saving her. The
film wound up being a hit at the box office,
raking in nearly $200 million domestically,
and it became the first horror movie to be
nominated for Best Picture at the Academy Awards.
Obviously, there was a market for Pazuzu, and
in 1977, he and Regan made a comeback with
The Exorcist II: The Heretic. That film, which
attempted to expand upon the demonic lore of the
first with psychic healers and doppelgängers, was
a failure both critically and financially. But in
1990, Blatty returned to the franchise, serving
as both writer and director of The Exorcist III.
Ignoring the events of The Heretic, The Exorcist
III follows William Kinderman, a police lieutenant
investigating a series of deaths that look like
those committed by a now-dead serial killer.
Jason Miller reprises his role as Karras,
who, after having survived the Regan exorcism,
is now being used as a killer conduit.
While not without its faults, The Exorcist
III is a vast improvement on its predecessor.
It's thoughtful, and both Scott and Miller are
exceptional. In an unfortunate turn of events,
however, Blatty was forced to add an exorcism
sequence to the end, forever marring a film that
would have otherwise been a haunting and
cerebral followup worthy of his original.
When Wes Craven's A Nightmare on Elm Street hit
theaters in 1984, it was like nothing horror fans
had ever seen before — a killer targeting teens
in their dreams, a community of adults behind a
massive coverup, and a villain so terrifying
that he kept both the film's characters and
its audience awake at night. Robert Englund built
his entire career around Freddy Krueger, a role he
credits for making him, quote, "an international
actor overnight," and since first donning that
knifed glove, he's gone on to play the killer
seven more times. As the franchise went on,
however, it became a parody of itself, and Freddy
was relegated to little more than a caricature.
But Craven always was the kind of writer/director
who thrived on turning things on their head,
and, like he did with the horror genre in 1984, he
flipped the narrative of his original masterpiece
a decade later with Wes Craven's New Nightmare.
Reuniting original cast members as real-life
versions of themselves who wind up terrorized
by a demonic force posing as Freddy Krueger,
New Nightmare has almost nothing to do with
the original Nightmare on Elm Street narrative.
Instead, it examines the horror industry itself,
as well as the legacy of Craven's original
film and the franchise it created.
"The problem comes when the story dies.
And that can happen in a lot of ways,
it can get too familiar to people, or someone
waters it down to make it an easier sell.”
It's meta at its very best, and it in fact serves
as a sort of warm-up to Craven's 1996 hit Scream.
The approach proved successful with both
critics and audiences. Wes Craven's New
Nightmare is considered one of the best in the
entire series, second only to the original.
Comedies in the early aughts were often over the
top, raunchy, and ridiculous. Stoner comedies,
which were exceptionally popular at the time,
were all of these things... but with an added
layer of unlikely drug-induced hijinks.
Enter Harold & Kumar Go to White Castle,
a 2004 film that follows the titular characters
on a pot-fueled quest to satiate their late night
munchies. The pair are thrust into a series of
misadventures but ultimately find their way,
thanks in part to Neil Patrick Harris.
While not an Oscar contender by any means,
Harold & Kumar Go to White Castle received
generally favorable reviews upon its release,
mostly on account of its
likable leads and edgy humor.
Although its 2008 followup, Harold & Kumar
Escape From Guantanamo Bay, was decidedly less
successful, John Cho and Kal Penn reunited once
more in 2011 for A Very Harold & Kumar Christmas,
a 3D holiday film that revisits the duo two
years after having gone their separate ways.
Like the films that came before it, A Very Harold
& Kumar Christmas tends toward lowbrow humor, but
not at all to the extent that Guantanamo Bay did.
Instead, Christmas leans into the holiday spirit,
tempering its crass comedy
with genuine feel-good moments.
That isn't to say that it will ever
become a holiday classic, but it's
an entertaining final installment to a franchise
that understood when it was time to say goodbye.
There's much to be said for Robert Zemeckis'
1985 time travel comedy Back to the Future.
Telling the story of high schooler Marty
McFly, who, with the help of inventor
Doc Brown, travels back in time to save his
parents' marriage and his future existence,
Back to the Future is, to this day, one of the
most beloved and original movies ever made.
It was both a critical and financial
success, going on to become the highest
grossing film of 1985. It was nominated for
four Academy Awards, including Best Screenplay,
and The New York Times lists it as one of the
Best 1000 Movies Ever Made. There are two sequels,
and while 1989's Back to the Future Part II
is the one that's remembered most by fans,
it's Back to the Future Part III that's
the forgotten gem of the franchise.
"Great scott!"
After learning of Doc's death in 1885 at the
hands of Biff Tannen's great-grandfather Mad Dog,
Marty travels back to the Old West in order to
save him. Part III has a much simpler narrative
than Part II, but it's helped along with a fun and
interesting setting, a locomotive time machine,
and a love interest for Doc that, quite frankly,
was well deserved. The film was also a bigger
hit with critics than the prior installment, with
the general consensus being that its paring down
of plot elements worked in its favor. It may not
be the cultural powerhouse that the original is,
but it definitely keeps from falling into
the franchise trap of unworthy sequels.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.